I've seen the entire series I really
want to say congratulations I thought
you did such a great job with this role
I appreciate it thank you Steve listen
you've done some really cool stuff in
your career uh and maybe it's this
project but I'm curious um if no one if
someone has never seen anything you've
done what is the first thing you'd like
them watching and why to be perfectly
honest with you it would be the crowded
room I am so proud of this project I'm
so proud of what everyone's achieved I
think that we've found the perfect
balance to a show that is you know
nostalgic to the 1970s while also being
incredibly unique and unlike any TV show
that's ever come before it and I got to
produce it I got to star in it I'm
incredibly proud of my work I'm proud of
everyone's work I think the show is
really fantastic I think it's exciting
so if I had to guide anyone to any bit
of work that I'd done it would be the
crowded room one of the things about
this project is you mentioned it you're
a producer you're the lead actor and
you're playing a tough role like
something that you really got to give
your all to but what is it like at the
end of the day when you're shooting some
intense scenes and then you've got to
put the producer hat on and then you got
to try to find Tom again before going
right back to set the next day I mean
yeah you're right it's a tough it's a
tough ask and you know I I didn't take
that new responsibility lightly I was
very involved I was very Hands-On I
wanted to be as involved as they would
allow me to be
um and it was tough it required a lot of
focus it meant that you know my days
were longer and my nights were shorter
and uh it was it was tough but it was so
rewarding I really do think I've left my
mark on this show I'm proud of the stuff
that I've done as a producer I'm proud
what I stood up for
um and I'm just really excited for the
fans to see it I want to ask a specific
question as a producer what was
something that you saw while the show
was being made that you're like oh we
need to do this and sort of exerted your
producer hat to make sure it happened
that's a good question I mean there are
many things we shot we we re-shot
sequences per my request you know we
change certain aspects of episodes per
my request
um I was very you know involved in the
edit with Akiva and our wonderful
editors on a weekly basis we would sit
down and have these Mammoth sessions
where we would go through the episodes
um you know I I I'd like to keep those
to myself because you know the the show
is a piece of magic and it shouldn't be
about whose decision was that and whose
decision was this
um but I know what it is and I'm really
proud of it what is it like when you're
in the editing room and you're literally
judging your own performance you know
what I mean like you're looking at your
work and maybe you have the the ability
to say to the director I think take two
is better you know what I mean like
where is that line it's an interesting
one I feel like I wasn't the best judge
of character when it came to my own
performance
um I think Akiva and our editors did an
amazing job of putting forward the best
I had to offer um yeah
I really enjoyed kind of figuring out
how we could manipulate the story to you
know keep the the evolution of the show
constantly changing even when we were
editing it we were moving episodes
around episode one became episode five
episode five became episode one and and
we were constantly adapting the show
um so I guess I guess I didn't have that
much input into my own performance I
trusted in them there's a few times
where I said can I have a look at a few
takes and we changed a few things but
all in all I trusted them to do the
right thing and I really believed that
they did